the watch Hong's are the rock formations
in New Jersey right that route 280 right
route 280 wasn't built around the watch
Chung's route 280 went through the watch
hugs like when you're carving a new path
that's what I feel like my experience
has been like the watch ons right your
your first it's explosive you have to
blast through that rock and then you
have to lay a foundation and then you
have to build a road and then you watch
as civilization travels on that road
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saki on we
are on site at Studio One at 'yes'
Venice campus we're gonna be talking
about all things cannabis all things
health and wellness all things on-demand
cannabis and much more I'm super excited
blessed honored to have Jason Pitts be
joining us on the show what's up brother
greetings thank you for coming on that
was a she ate it super excited to talk
about all this for those who don't know
Jason Pinsky's background said 25 years
in cannabis
tech food and media he's cannabis
producer for vice lands bon appetit
which has went through 40 episodes in
three seasons he's the first credited
cannabis producer on IMDB he's a king of
mainstream marijuana awarded by cannabis
Business Awards and he's the chief
cannabis evangelist here at ease where
one of his focuses is creating content
that is educational inspirational and
breeds enthusiasm for the team and
outward alright I love starting with a
big history synthesis on reality so Ari
we find ourselves here as stewards of
Earth after a long period of evolution
and we are going through a period of
hockey stick in our population growth
hockey stick and exponential technology
and we have now unleashed a lot of love
earth's resources in terms of cannabis
and other plant medicines i would like
to know what is your synthesis about the
current state of humanity i believe we
are at a point in time where we are
expanding our consciousness as a as a
society as humanity collectively and
cannabis is a THC in the plant medicine
that comes from gaia right mother earth
is speaking through us at this point and
what it's allowing is it's allowing for
us to get access to a core nutrient that
is core to maintaining homeostasis
within our bodies which is keeping our
body and our physical space in balance
and that is it's like are you familiar
with Maslow's hierarchy of needs so it's
right so like if the foundation it's
triangular shaped in nature I like
Maslow's triangle hey you got to wake up
and make you bet every morning man you
got to have your like you know your if
you're if you're moving toward you know
I'm not only a higher consciousness but
also you know self-actualization right
it starts with your core and your
environment you like make your bed clean
your office like start with your
physical space being in order and our
physical space and this time is our
vessel right our body right and cannabis
is the essential nutrient that allows us
to keep our vessel in optimum health by
keeping the chemical signaling and
chemical balance within our bodies right
so I believe that the work that we're
doing today with plant medicines that
are endogenous right chemical compounds
in the plant exist endogenously in our
bodies right the reason I refer to it
a supplement or a nutrient is is because
we as a civilization are kind of going
through what's referred to as an
endocannabinoid deficiency syndrome so
if you think about the intention of
usage in the last century all right in
our lifetimes and there are parents and
grandparents lifetime it is different
than the intention and usage going back
to the beginning of civilization right
cannabis is unlike other plant medicines
that have have a a hallucinogenic effect
cannabis has an theo genic effect
right the the word and theage in' right
and and it's interesting in the open we
talked about educating and inspiring to
breed enthusiasm and enthusiasm comes
from the root of that word of a plant
that is an entheogen which doesn't just
make you see something but it really
inspires and elicits like a you know you
could call it a god-like experience but
it's not necessarily that you have to
believe in God right what it what it has
done for me is it has started me on the
path to be open-minded toward to be
quantum in my thinking to be open-minded
toward any and every possibility in
terms of outcome and not necessarily be
attached and cannabis is is in my
opinion the first step in terms of us
getting our bodies and balance and
preparing for the next step you know we
see the cannabis movement and we see the
cannabis industry following that
movement and then coming is like this
whole secondary movement of other plant
medicines that also contain things in
the plant that are endogenous that
exists within our bodies already so
that's the area of focus that I'm
interested in is how these plants act as
a nutrient and or a supplement
and the order in which right we do that
and you know it's it's important to
really kind of look at this cannabis
movement as a step yeah it's a gateway
to an expanded consciousness that's the
gateway drug okay so I like how you took
us to that our awareness we are
awakening through some of Mother Earth's
plant medicines and we are hopefully
moving towards a unity here but we came
from evolution all with the plants and
animals as one and we need to awaken to
that oneness to best prosper
collectively moving forward so it took a
while for all of what we see to be
happening with the not only the
incredible access to ubiquity and food
and water and shelter and electricity
education the internet healthcare but
especially cannabis kids like your son
don't necessarily see the lineage of the
last 50 or 60 years that blood sweat
tears deaths long periods of time
fighting for cannabis to be able to
reactivate people so tell us about what
that journey has been 25 years for you
tell us about what this journey has been
like for those that may not necessarily
that just go to the dispensary and
they're like great here's some cannabis
but they don't know this history my
history of cannabis was like any young
man I really recently discovered that
I'm 99.8% full Jew Ashkenazi Jew on 23
May I gave away my DNA happily and yeah
it's interesting right because you at
some point
right you are I've given up on my
privacy in exchange for technology which
is changing slowly because we will be
decentralizing these data silos and then
making it easier for people to get paid
for their data as a potential universal
basic in I've just accepted the
convenience and I've also been confident
and Integris in my actions and over the
last several years as I've kind of
emerged as a public figure in this space
and like maybe when I set my my facebook
to public posts you know at some point
you have to just like you know be
Integris with your actions and then all
of a sudden certainly privacy has a huge
value but when you're building a brand
around yourself around your lifestyle
and kind of putting a lot of your stuff
out there and granted it's edited and
you know curated right but on the same
token like I understand the value of all
the technology and I'd rather be have
access to the technology in and and
versus my other friends who are like I
want my privacy you and then they and
then they won't go on social media and
they won't like live in 2019 and with
further steps in encryption and new
protocols that enable the fluid data
flows to occur I think will pass a you
will have a very interesting cannabis
history so you know tell us what is it
well I get a right of passage
Pinsky and we can call you know Jason by
his last name Penske is a great last
name goes by for sure so Penske has a
cool background where he you had an
experience where you yourself had a
serious surgical serious spinal injury
and surgery that then took you into
opioids use for a long period of time
and then cannabis helped you taper off
of that yeah let's just say that my
intention of using cannabis came from
you know the allure of seeing being a
child of the 70s and seeing the music
and hippie culture in the 60s and you
know like the intention was to try to
get high right like seeing that in the
media and seeing how the play
was portrayed and I was like cool and
then you know coming through that
experience all through high school and
college you know I didn't think of
cannabis as a medical product until you
know great that twenty years into my
experience with the plan I mean you know
the intention had always been to to
really get high as a matter of fact
living in New York hearing the term
medical marijuana and thinking about
what was happening in California you
know to me that was like oh yeah anyone
could go to Venice to the boardwalk and
get a script and for a headache and you
know just didn't really actually seem
real to me and then I found myself
injuring my spine and getting prescribed
oxycontin for close to 14 years it was
twelve years that I was on it then I had
a second injury on a motorcycle which
caused me to go in for surgery a second
time and now when you are opiate
dependent for over a decade and then you
need another surgery you have to really
carefully balance the anaesthesia to put
you down the amount of medication that
you need post surgically it really
becomes like a specialized case and just
to put it into perspective when I had my
injury in September of 2000 was when I
had my surgery I I wound up after 11
years on close to 12 to 1500 milligrams
a day every 24 hours of oxycontin now
this is what we refer to as a lethal
dose okay if someone was to take a
thousand milligrams of oxycontin cold
you're you would die I mean your heart
either sorry you would stop breathing
what happens is it's your opiate
receptor your opiate receptor exists in
your brain stem
in your brain and it can get you know
like so hit so hard that your core
function
like breathing right is is impacted a
lot of people who you see dying from an
opiate overdose is because their
respiratory system slows down to the
point and they pass out in their body
forgets to breathe and this is the huge
difference and what I started to learn
after my second surgery and after I
actually had some downtime right - to
start studying the endocannabinoid
system and I was able to really kind of
look at wow you know Washington and
Colorado had passed their legislation in
2012 and this was right at the time
where I had my second surgery right at
the time where after 20 years in
business I was kind of forced to be on
the DL I'm a disabled list I had to heal
a leg injury I was home for six months
and this is within the timeframe that
cannabis legislation was advancing in
Colorado and Washington and I had an
opportunity to really kind of see that
there were other people and now this is
after YouTube had started to come out
you can't really you know Oaksterdam
University like you know all of these
different resources for cannabis
education did not exist right so I got a
huge education based on some anecdotal
stories and some were physicians PhDs
and and and and doctors and you know
scientists chemists people that were
really starting to look at the plant
from a more analytical approach and
starting to really the discovery of the
endocannabinoid system and I started to
kind of look at medical cannabis from a
different perspective in terms of like
how could this help me right
get off of opiates after you know 11 or
12 years so that was my my journey was
like starting out from a intentional
place of trying to maybe get high or
trying to escape and then using my
background in technology as a computer
scientist to become almost like a
animus right scientist and and my
knowledge of biology and chemistry
wasn't traditional my knowledge of
biology and chemistry was as it related
to cannabis chemistry and the compounds
that the plant was made of and then
within our bodies how those chemicals
interfaced with our bodies and taking us
into my starting to learn about the
endocannabinoid system and the
difference between like an opiate
receptor and a cannabinoid receptor
right the opiate receptors are in your
brainstem
I think the cannabinoid receptors are
everywhere else in your brain not in
your brainstem so no matter how high you
get on the weed no matter how much of it
you ingest you're never gonna overdose
you're never gonna die you're never
gonna stop breathing because it just
doesn't impact the body in the same way
and really starting to understand that
the chemicals in the plant
all right phyto cannabinoids as we've
further classified them right supplement
the endocannabinoids in our bodies and
this whole concept of the
endocannabinoid system and these
compounds and the receptors and then
what they're what are they there for
well they're there to create chemical
balance and homeostasis right walgreens
shoutout Hey right walgreens didn't
exist back in the in the beginning of
time right we were put on this earth
with the best pharmacy almost on the
corner in us and then it's these
nutrients and things you know that were
designed to help us and most of them
were designed to to come from plants
right I mean there's certainly the
argument that humanity really like you
know caught supercharged when we started
to to eat you know red meat and whatnot
and and and I do I own a barbecue place
in New York you know what I mean I'm no
stranger to that but in the last few
years as I've become active in the
cannabis movement it's really opened my
eyes to to plants in our connection with
them you have two crucial things you
brought up there within your story it
so important to identify how many other
people as well are experiencing severe
opiate addictions and also veterans that
are now we're running shoutout to maps
helping run really important cannabis
trials this is a new way for us to like
you said the intent setting intent
you mentioned this now many times the
intent to heal the Intel intent to
commune with earth and with each other
that is so precious and so important we
started talking about the mitten the
medicinal benefits and the health and
wellness now of so many people being
augmented due to cannabis roaring and we
see it now across the world slowly
emerging more and more countries more
and more growth was just reading about
tons of different countries in Africa
now starting to really grow and prosper
with cannabis and I'm like damn nice so
tell us about your thoughts on a more
abstract global level on cannabis coming
in as a medicine and its impact I don't
know I don't necessarily think it's a
medicine I make a country and supplement
anchor yes I make AI make a correlation
to to we'd like water we all know that
we need to supplement our bodies with
eight glasses of water every day to
maintain optimal hydration it's a
well-known fact if we overdose on water
right that could actually kill you you
touch the water too quickly
alright that could kill you
I think we need to look at weed in a
similar way I think we need to look at
it as our bodies contain these
endocannabinoids all right what's
happening is you have your own erro
transmitters right and you've got
synapses and they move from your
presynaptic to your postsynaptic they
move in one direction because that's
from pre to post like a one-way street
and no cannabinoids are actually
manufactured by the post-synaptic and
travel in Reverse from post to pre and
then from pre to post so what you have
is a bi-directional communication
pathway the only one in the body now the
science behind why the endocannabinoid
system is kind of like the body's master
thermostat right is because it can send
chemical signals in both ways a really
good example of that is inflammation
right in my case is a chronic pain
patient I used cannabis as an
anti-inflammatory in the case of the US
government who ironically has a patent
on cannabis as a neuro protectant for
traumatic brain injury it's used in an
inflammatory capacity to protect or
protect him the body has the ability to
use these tools so when I think of it
and describe it as a supplement right
imagine Humanity if we were limited
access to water and if society at large
was chronically dehydrated how would
that impact our health right if we stop
thinking about the intention of cannabis
for getting high and we start thinking
about it as a nutrient and a supplement
and preventative ly like you're one a
day should have low dose compounds that
exist in this plant just like iron and
potassium all these different things
that our body needs envisioning cannabis
in this way is really interesting it's a
good analogy this nutrient supplement
and being dehydrated of it across the
world and then activating it it's very
cool I like how you're bringing the
sub-question interjecting is out of the
seven point seven billion of us how many
do you believe needs a nutrient because
water
everyone needs okay seven point seven
billion of us okay we are made of mostly
water we are all wired for weed
we've all got an endocannabinoid system
we all require this essential nutrient
all of us
some of us may require maybe a milligram
or two I'm talking the lowest the lowest
Oh without the intention of being high
with the intention of nutrients
supplement correct interesting okay and
this is not just humans and if this is
all vertebrates and this goes back to
the beginning of time to like sea
squirts all right the evidence of
endocannabinoids and endocannabinoid
receptors goes back to the beginning of
life itself that's what's up interesting
I wonder how many other scientists first
of all I'd like to have more a couple
more interviews with endocannabinoid
specific scientists of the system in the
body - I wonder how many scientists /
just people in general would be would
slightly refute that all seven point
seven billion need even a milligram -
per day so interesting that that's
that's a perspective yeah I'm not a
scientist and I tend to regurgitate
information that seems logical and makes
sense to me you should look up a
gentleman named dr. Bob Mela Mead okay
he's amazing he was one of the first
guys on YouTube that like I learned
about this stuff from he is it's got a
few letters after his name he's I
believe he's a chemist or biologist or
you know as you know with your boy he's
you're I'm already gonna reach out
tonight via email and easily how dr. Bob
dr. Bob Minsky Pinsky says what's up at
Pinsky says was could also reach out to
dr. Ethan Rousseau okay and Rousseau is
the one that coined this term I believe
the clinical and no cannabinoid
deficiency syndrome very interesting
endocannabinoid deficiency syndrome
that's so interesting for me to poke out
with a scientific prod and just try and
understand that better because I don't
necessarily know how many saw
even know about the think about it as a
deficient and nutrient deficiency and
then people don't when out of the people
that walk into dispensaries when I watch
them when I talk to them most people
aren't coming in for a nutrient
deficiency the intent is not that so I
love the way that you're framing this
this is what I meant earlier talking
about rewriting the narrative on
cannabis to a global audience yes yes so
we let's okay let's jump into this
because you are rewriting the cannabis
narrative to a global audience and
you're doing that with ease ease is
doing it as facilitating the access to
this nutrient and then with Bon Appetit
you're rewriting the cannabis narrative
to global audience through media so
let's talk about let's talk about those
two let's break them down the intention
on Bon Appetit was a cooking show that
was cooking with cannabis right we
didn't know going in that we were going
to create something that was going to
rewrite the narrative on weed itself and
I think the formula for success on that
again which just kind of happened we
never set out with the intention of
saying we need to do a show that's going
to have all this amazing undertone
that's gonna make families connect from
parents to children that's going to
portray this in such a great light we
never knew then that result of what was
gonna come out of it until it happened
and when you're creating something from
nothing I mean that's very often that
that happens in creation my role on the
show is cannabis producer was behind the
scenes although there is one episode of
me donning Pinsky's glasses and the the
bathrobe in our pot head sleepover
really funny we all got together and
watched like reefer madness and ate
brownies we were like the antithesis of
like we're not gonna do a show that's
cookies and brownies that story's been
told you know when I first sat down with
the executive producers advice
with a chemistry set full of cannabis
stuff and they're like Penske no way man
like this is never gonna translate like
we're not doing a science show we're
doing a Food Show it's part of iceland's
part of vices munchies vertical its food
focused and and I think it was a it was
a little bold but I was like guy it's
look you guys have an obligation advise
not to tell the same story yeah how many
people are cooking with weed butter and
you know we have an opportunity to talk
about like all these new products all
these new methods of extraction all this
new product development these textures
these finishes and then when you take
the plant and you refine it to the
traditional hash that everyone knows the
Lebanese and like what you can get an
Amsterdam back in the 80s and 90s and
still today right which is a primitive
mechanical separation style okay you
further refine that into what we refer
to as concentrates or extracts and then
all the different textures and finishes
butters rosin dabs shatter you know all
these concentrated forms right and then
you further refine that into the oil
that we see in vape pens if you further
take that and distill it and you take
this like cannabis oil and you pull it
apart and then you just have all these
isolated compounds your THC is over here
and your CBD is over here but what you
have is this multitude of fragrance
compounds that are in the plant the
Terps the terpenes right and that to me
is really the the most interesting part
right for me and that's what really
translates to food because now what we
can do is we can create a pantry a
pallet so to speak of new ingredients
all right what happens when Picasso gets
like a whole new paint set right this
was the genesis of what we tried to
capture on the show we would not let
these chefs in the pantry and we would
not choose chefs that were cannabis
savvy
right we wanted iron chef's master chefs
we wanted to capture that aha Genesis
moment
that's what's translating to the
audience when you at home see someone
having that experience of newness
discovery these are the things that it
takes to rewrite the narrative right and
then to be able to say to a chef okay
this is just the THC you could make your
dish you could use all your flavor
profiles THC isolate has no flavor or
fragrance so you could just add a little
bit of the medicinal or the euphoric to
your creation and then we say hey this
is our terpene section all these
different fragrances they have no
psychoactive effect you could pair them
with your food this is our CDD area this
is no psycho activity you know I mean
there's now a whole new thinking
perspective if you will on how to use
this plant okay and the difference
between fractioning it off and using it
in all these you know these vape pens
that you see on the market these days
our distillate distilled THC with
different flavor profiles some that come
from the plant and some that come from
other flavor sources okay and when you
think about that and the intention that
most people are using that for just to
get high right you miss the opportunity
for the most therapeutic impact the best
therapy from the plant comes from what
we refer to as whole plant medicine when
you extract all the compounds from the
plant and you ingest that that's the
type of plant medicine that is switching
on the body's natural mechanism to take
cells that are damaged and shut them off
right that process you can check with
your scientist friends it's called
apoptosis right people used to use
cannabis in a way that was
like more of a reactionary right cancer
AIDS right you're gonna get a
prescription for weed it's gonna help
with your appetite nausea why because
smoking weed is a very primitive
delivery and whereas there's like a
cannabis a THC could be in its isolated
form as a hundred percent pure THC when
you're ingesting it obvious smoking it
via joint five percent ten percent right
so this is what happened with me in my
medical journey was the product
development of these taking it from the
plant and making all these products that
we started to use on Bon Apetit right
because of the advancement in science
analytics being able to break down the
compounds in the plant and report on
that now breeders are able to like breed
up certain cannabinoids breed down
others this was the road map for the
hemp movement of the the CBD movement or
is all because analytics were able to
allow people to breed low THC cannabis
qualifies as hemp under the farm bill
newsflash okay they're smoking weed
they're growing weed man okay that's the
news flash but it qualifies as hemp
because of the amount of THC that's in
it and most of those varieties are high
in CBD and we were able to breed like
that because we had the testing and the
analytics yes right to be able to see
what was in it but really at the end of
the day the most therapeutic impact from
the plant comes from all of the
compounds working synergistically
together okay so a couple things first I
love how you made the push for the media
that you're producing with Bon Appetit
to be
more at least a little bit scientific
because you have them you have an
obligation to communicate a new
narrative that new narrative being this
whole plant as a supplement as a
nutrient and I ah've wanna and you also
identified and articulated the nuance
that we can now with the again we talked
about that exponential technology hockey
stick we can break down cannabinoids to
a new degree to the nuance of terpenes
to the nuance of all the different
cannabinoid profiles and and play with
food with that which is super exciting
and see which properties are actually
going to be best for our own health and
wellness keeping in use keep in mind
that represented 10% of the show exactly
and this is so this is the point and
just to bring you full triangle so to
speak Bon Appetit was a success because
it was authentic to the core community
who already had the legacy and who
really wanted to see the advancement of
the products but it was palatable to a
mainstream audience through food as
everyone eats food so because we really
put ourselves forward as a food focused
show that was the main ingredient that
was the main thing that translated to a
global audience because everybody eats
okay the cannabis story which was
underlying okay was authentic because we
were telling the story of the
advancement in product development
through science and whatnot yeah now
that is you know you mentioned here I
want to just hear your thoughts on this
before as we move into how you're doing
similar work with with ease on the whole
plant as a nutrient supplement side of
things this has now been this has talked
about a new West Summit this talked
about by Mark Gordon and so many other
leaders that the whole plant is the
Metis
is the supplement the nutrient teach us
about that well there's about 400
chemical compounds in the plant right
some of them are like the the plant
material itself right but when you do an
extraction right you're you're taking
out all these cannabinoids and all these
terpenes and they work in a synergistic
a function with one another
Raphael michele l'm and the guy who did
the CNN Sanjay Gupta right they referred
to it on weeds right a weed 1.0 weed 2.0
myrrh but that stuff 2012-13 was like
wow Sanjay Gupta oh my god you've heard
of this concept called the entourage
effect think of it like a rock band or
think of it like a symphony interesting
right like so like you know like you
know THC is like the lead guitar man
it's like Garcia alright he's out front
fat man's getting it you know what I
mean but like you're not gonna be the
Grateful Dead without like all of the
dudes in the band yeah I like to refer
to to cannabis as like remember that old
Cheech and Chong movie where they're
actually driving a vehicle made of weed
and the tailpipe catches on fire and the
whole thing starts to so if you think of
weed like a car right a THC right is I
let the gas pedal all right and then the
terpenes are like your steering wheel
and they work synergistically with one
another right the terpenes essentially
steer the direction of your high okay so
these days are indica sativa right these
notions are being debunked right indica
meaning a the region of the plant that
it was origin from India where there's a
lot of Sun and these plants grow short
and stocky and sativas usually stretch
up to the sky they're grown in the
mountains where
you know they where there's less you
know what the plane needs to get more
gnarly and you know it just so happened
that the shape of those plants and the
terpene profiles that were associated
with those plants a sativa would give
you that up and an indica would give you
that that down bow now through analytics
and lab testing and looking at these
different varieties and then also
looking at the terpene profiles it turns
out that it's these fragrance compounds
in conjunction with the THC that are
really steering the direction of your
high it's not the shape of the leaf of
the plant that determines how it makes
you feel and then the other variable
that's really interesting is us okay we
are the variable our DNA our physiology
I'll smoke some weed and it'll make me
film the same weed and it makes me feel
different than you well we're different
all right so now you've got like you
know groups that are like taking your
DNA and starting to associate that right
so your DNA in your body composition
you've other groups that are taking the
DNA from the plant itself all right how
many versions of Sour Diesel are out
there right so like you know we are
cloning plants like that's acceptable
so we're cloning plants but still like
now you might have the same genetics but
then you've got different nutrients
you've got different Sun you've got
different lighting variables all these
different things so getting consistency
in this it's really difficult and
there's two ways to do it you can grow
the plant and then try to extract the
oil in the medicine from the plant and
then come up with a product that's what
people are isolating and distal aiding
and then taking all these things and
trying to make their own formulations
then you have other dudes that are like
growing cannabinoids on like yeast in
like so when Pharma comes into this
right they're not going to be growing
fields of weed and waiting three months
for plants to mature and then extracting
those and hoping
to isolate all these compounds they're
just gonna start with they're gonna grow
THC in and these things can already be
done they haven't been done in scale as
you see the transition into a cannabis
medicine and it's interesting because
Pharma will quite often try to take
something in nature and synthesize it
and own it and patent it and and and one
compound at that cannabis working
symbiotically synergistically with all
these compounds that are in the plant
makes it a little harder to own that
type of IP you when you mentioned the
the symphony that was very interesting
that that's where the whole plant
nutrient kicks in as this whole symphony
as an entourage and then you also
brought us to the the gas pedal and the
in the steering wheel for the THC and
the terpenes I thought that was very
interesting these are good and now just
to give people thinking in new ways and
innovative ways around cannabis again
changing the narrative it's very
beautiful the new involvement and the
new innovations that come from farm
pharma jumping in potentially big
alcohol but tobacco may be jumping in
etc what's gonna spur as creative from
from Israel and from Africa and from
different areas around the world will be
also very interesting to to Devon
alright Penske we got to hear about this
so you're also facilitating the nutrient
access of cannabis through ease
on-demand correct ease uh well first of
all let me just say this that the
underlying story that we're providing
access to this plant medicine is not how
we mark it is not how cannabis brands
market themselves it's not how ease
markets ourselves what is ease ease is
the marketplace that and the ecosystem
that's what we create we create the
software the tools and through our
partnerships with retailers
with product manufacturers right we have
off all of us collectively create this
environment and with customers
all right so customers come onto a menu
on their phone he's calm and they are
shown products that are relevant to
their location so what we do is we work
with cannabis licensed brands to bring
their products onto our menu and into
the marketplace and then we work with
retailers and those retailers are the
and the transactions happening between
the customer and the retailer which is
happening within our marketplace
marketplace ecosystem so easy sensually
is facilitating on-demand cannabis and
and it's really a beautiful thing in I
mean like you know in some cases you can
get a delivery of weed in six minutes 10
minutes 15 minutes right I mean there's
really the fact that cannabis became the
first product that you can get in that
short of a time frame is awesome
it is yeah damn that is the future of
being able to get on demand products and
especially when it's a nutrient you
would like it in a short bit of time
well look I mean people aren't thinking
of it like I'm preaching this gospel of
it being a nutrient and that's like the
foundation it's like the Solfeggio scale
right so like the nutrient story is like
174 Hertz man it's like it's below your
root chakra okay it's like the one that
you don't even know about but like it's
the foundation of everything else that's
happening right the narrative and the
story is not like we're providing
essential nutrients to humanity okay
that's what's happening right Dennis
Peron said it well he said there's no
such thing as a recreational use it's
all medicinal use no matter what your
intention is you are actually helping
your body
by supplementing it with these compounds
that exists in our bodies naturally so
ease you know we really are I'm the
chief cannabis evangelist at ease but
really at the end of the day I don't
think of myself as an evangelist for
ease definitely an evangelist for
cannabis these ease happens to be and
that's what we want we want to we want
to highlight cannabis we want to
highlight the brand the brands and the
products right and that's what's so
interesting about this industry right
now right what we're really talking
about is broccoli okay cannabis is and
will continue to be and will be more
obviously seen as a commodity cost of
production will go down lettuce dude
that's what this is how cheap is a head
of lettuce there's no value to it
practically and if I look at my history
in right but there is value to the
brands right like you're buying
commodity products based on the trust
that you have for the brand that is
associated with that product
look I watched this happen in technology
man I used to be in the tech business I
used to create software then we got into
internet and we got into hosting an
email and web and all these different
things that I was able to charge
hundreds of dollars a month minase it
charged 25 bucks a month per mailbox
right then all of a sudden Google came
around and all these different brands
came around and then it was like we're
gonna give away the technology for free
but you're gonna take our brand name and
use it in your email address and so
what's happening in the cannabis
industry right now is the cost of the
weed is just continuing to go down and
down him down so creating your brand is
actually of a high value pun intended
right and that's what I think is
happening here at ease and this is why I
want to be able to
work with content right Bon Appetit was
really special because it gave cannabis
brands an opportunity to be featured on
of the world stage what it lacked was
the opportunity for the people watching
to get access to those products at a
click of a button I suppose was even in
general that brand even in general man
bon appetit may have been Fantasy Island
right it may have been The Bachelor it
was something that was happening in
California in a moment of time where we
were able to shoot that show but like
even the people watching the broad scale
of them were unable to get the products
that they saw on the show right because
they were not necessarily available in
the marketplace because they were and we
were isolating you're seeing these THC
diamonds and crystals and that's not on
retail shelves at the dispensary right
so we had an opportunity to have great
brand exposure on the show we helped to
build and create brands yeah okay but
what's happened is retail has gone from
brick and mortar to mail-order with the
invention of the internet and now is
moving toward on-demand mm-hmm right
consumers want products on demand
consumers want rideshare on demand
consumers want media on demand
okay so ease is filling that void and
really the reason why I think it's so
interesting to be able to create content
that features products and then move
into a new phase where we are creating a
menu that allows those products to get
right how do we take that full triangle
yep all right so this is really my new
role at ease it's creating content that
features products that are on our menu
that you can get on demand and you know
you mentioned retail I mean this game
changes retail because these products
are we today
the delivery environment vehicle is easy
but that lends itself toward other
content featuring other products that
people can get so the fact again that
cannabis becomes the product that really
sets the stage for game-changing and
disrupting retail my product placement
is cool product placement is cool
product placement is cool but product
placement fulfillment on demand is
really cool really cool that's the
triangle with the fulfillment I like
that and I want to touch on this is
important you you mentioned this as a
broccoli a lettuce and I want to know
more so on the intent side you've
mentioned intent several times this is
really important the intent taken in as
a nutrient or a supplement as prone said
is very holistic it feels so that feels
good it feels right at the same time
where there's a couple things here
there's a little bit of there's a little
bit of like an escapist culture
happening at times I have this is so
hard there's so much work to do I'm just
the smoke chill or the food whatever
then there's also what age do we allow
this at there's a big age question going
on some scientists are urging us to post
postpone use until 21 and later tell us
about that both the little on the scape
ISM little on the youth I can speak to
both greatly because I used oxycontin as
a escape tool to escape a reality that I
was not happy with I used gaming as an
escape tool to enter into multiple
multiplayer MMO or massive multiplayer
online role-playing games right I spent
a decade deep in
are off you know what that means if you
know what that means as or off is the is
where one of the Warcraft happens so I
know about escape and I know about using
weed and I know about using oxycontin I
know about using virtual environments
that are immersive to escape totally you
know that if you take a plant cannabis
plant and you eat it raw right even just
the leaves not even the buds I never
hear the cannabis juicing is like the
new superfood cannabis leaves of the new
kale right THC in its raw form is called
THC a its non psychoactive doesn't get
you high amazing as a nutrient for the
body okay so if the intention is to use
cannabis that has been bred for high THC
with the intention of getting high and
combustion is never a good idea smoking
right and so smoking weed is a certainly
a primitive way but if you look at
civilizations back to the beginning of
time and have been using cannabis in
their food source
China India right look at the the Lost
Tribes the Lost Tribe of Jews that
became the Rastafarians that is a Star
of David dude right it's been a
long-standing relationships between Jews
and weed that goes back to the beginning
of time but even before that Indians
bongs
bong charas right all these different
preparations
China China did not only use cannabis
for bowstrings and industrial
applications if you look up the first
and faeo genic use of a plant in China
these dudes were buried with like weed
as like the sacrament right it's like
this holy plant right so when you think
of civilizations you ever see a
Rastafarian Jamaican dude that's like
years old and that guy is built like an
ox and still could run a hundred miles
you know that dude has been eating weed
his whole life potentially through other
sources such as the cannabis leaf a
scale could could could be consumed in
in salad type it will be interesting to
understand and better study the use for
for both intent for fur as a supplement
nutrient rather than escape as well as
for youth and approximately what the
benefits are in mind okay the difference
between THC a and THC THC a is non
psychoactive because it's THC with a
carboxylic acid chain on the end of the
molecule and because it's got that
carboxylic acid chain it can't penetrate
the blood-brain barrier doesn't enter
the bloodstream
therefore it's non psychoactive yeah
okay when the plant is growing its
growing THC a THC is a byproduct that
break with THC breaks down that
carboxylic acid either disintegrate it
you know breaks down through heat and
high heat it will break down instantly
at room temperature there's a curve and
it breaks down slowly over time and
that's what we call activating
activating it interesting the use of THC
a as our novice like plant raw you get
all these amazing nutrient benefits from
it you don't get high non psychoactive
but that's interesting yeah mm-hmm good
points good points okay I want to talk
about markets this is really important
this is being quoted to be a multi
hundred billion dollar if not trillion
dollar industry over the next century
and that the United States in many ways
has taken a backseat to other powers
like the United Kingdom Israel the
Netherlands Africa this is Canada and
cleanse somebody's going public
companies going public on the Canadian
stock exchange Israel having the
growing cannabis at the highest
qualities at less than 15 bucks an ounce
60 cents a gram commodity the commodity
and so Rockley broccoli so the united
states here and california through all
of its hard work of pushing the
narrative forward and making it happen
has again an obligation on a national
scale to prioritize the legalization of
cannabis for the nutritional the
supplemental purpose for humans not only
in the US but around the world and also
to advance innovation of some of the
most creative people in the world to be
able to innovate and create within the
cannabis industry publicly as it being
legal so i want to hear your thoughts on
the markets i think that the intent of
intention behind lawmakers has nothing
to do with the nutritional value of the
planet but one can see a direct effect
of lawmakers helping legalize means more
access absolutely yeah yeah but the
intention is money you're seeing this
happen on a broad scale where
politicians who have careers against
this plant our leaving office joining
companies all of a sudden things are
becoming legal i watched this happen in
New York State New York State you have
five companies that get awarded licenses
you know the companies that got awarded
licenses built the New York State
Thruway ran the electrical contracts on
Staten Island we're like you know like
come on dude look at what's actually
going on so there's two there's two
sides to this story right there's the
market and the movement right ease
operates on both sides of the coin we
have an entire company
the entire staff within our organization
that is dealing with research public
policy advancing legislation that has
nothing to do with our core business
social impact right all of these
different things that represent the
movement so you have the movement and
pushing the movement forward and then
you have the market and the money and
the profit and all these things and
personally I try to speak more toward
the movement right I recently had a
psychedelic experience where I was
asking myself a really important
question about my purpose I'm like man
what is my purpose in this like I'm part
of this movement a part of this company
ease you know can be perceived as big
weed right perception is really
important and then myself and my
authentic self my quest and my intention
and then also co-branding with this
company and it really made me ask myself
like okay dude
what is my purpose like what am I trying
to do like what's the bigger picture
outside of like my job here and creating
content and like for what am i trying to
effect change am I trying to make profit
am I trying to make profit or am I
trying to affect change man this was a
this was like a question that really
burned within me and what I realized was
that sometimes you have to make profit
to effect change that is correct I'm
glad that that was the realization so
when one is able to come from the soul
as I care most about the movement that
is what I care most about I care about
the movement towards a you
on this planet moving forward that
that's what I care about most at the
same time I understand that I can make
steps greater steps towards that unity
as we build things of valuing of the
world that then can help move the
movement forward yep I'm glad that they
are there and so that's one of the
reasons why I do think that the United
States picking up it's getting a little
fire under its butt to move forward and
the legalization will help advance the
move you know I will say this you know
you saw Amsterdam in terms of the
recreational market place right since
the late 80s coffee shops my first
cannabis cup competition was in 1994
it's 21 years old
okay and shout out to High Times for
creating media that has really been
pushing the envelope and telling the
story and you know shout out to also Jim
McAlpine with 420 games all the things
like that yeah exactly the all of the
amazing humans if that is in fact what
we are human animals and whatever's
coming through that I know that's coming
that's coming shortly that's actually
we're getting there we're getting there
shortly
[Laughter]
okay there is so many amazing souls that
are collectively pushing this movement
forward and it stems not only from
people who create communities or venues
but really all of the people that grow
the plant that processed the plant now
you're starting to see a convergence of
the legacy community and the the new
some people refer to as green rushers
here's the thing man
the legacy community needs the new
community the business community the
financial community the legislative
community the investment community you
know this is why I saw such an
opportunity at ease because most of the
professionals we have here within this
organization are professionals in their
respective fields and this is why the
target audience for me in the year and a
half that I've been here has been the
staff first because it was important to
me to make sure that everyone who was
expert in all these things that it takes
to build and create a business and to
fuel an industry and I were
authentically routed pun intended right
with our knowledge that's right right
education is always at the forefront
you know what the watch Chung's are
watch ons watch hug well Joe Chung's are
the rock formations in New Jersey right
that route 280 right route 280 wasn't
built around the watch ons root 280 went
through the watch Oaks right when you're
carving a new path mm-hmm that's what I
feel like my experience has been like
the watch honks that's right that's a
your your first it's explosive you have
to blast through that rock and then you
have to lay a foundation and then you
have to build a road and then you
as civilization travels on that road
that is very beautifully said and I
think that maybe the divine purpose of
so many of us beings on this planet is
to do exactly that that is uh that is so
gorgeous we we must it's our obligation
to create these roads that civilization
can advance on through our hard work of
making it happen and that is a lot of
what actualization is all about okay
this is something that we've been
talking about a lot it's really
important to to address how to best
handle this there seems to be a strong
good way of looking at this is a
topology a topology of influence a
topology of clout and as you start
laying you blast through that rock you
start laying the the road you gain
further and further up on this topology
and more and more people the network
continues to build especially once the
road is laid out and people are
civilizations starting to go down it
more and more connections more and more
Network effect is going on it's it's
difficult to figure out how to maximize
efficiencies with network so we see a
lot of times people get dragged out of
their most efficient habits by going
into areas of their network that may not
be as effective as if they kept climbing
and kept reaching out to more and more
diverse areas on the top of these
topologies so thoughts on this network
effective network Theory have you heard
of the Pinsky triangle that's please
explain the feeling it shines for me
it's it started about there are many
phases it's three-dimensional
it's actually a four-point geometric
it's a tetrahedron okay and and Wilkie
talk in terms of my career triangle to
start right media food tech weed as we
talked about in the show open today in
the 90s I was connecting the dots what
we do in life is we establish these
points okay for me it was media started
with music okay weed and tech the 90s
somehow I was able to connect the dots
and really you know I worked in
technology at a software company okay at
night I would record music live music
and through that music community forged
a lot of relationships with cannabis
cultivators and you know cannabis and
and music were kind of like my passion
points and then Tech was how I made my
living and then over the course of my
career food came into the equation
you know the 90s it was like people
often not only established these points
but then connecting the dots okay is
everything and back in the day it was
music and weed music and weed is an easy
connection right and then tech and I
couldn't really really go forward with
the weed thing because in 1994 93 it was
like illegal right so the music in tech
became the two points that I was
connecting right but music and tech and
weed and then I really started to propel
my career in that geometry and then 15
years later I added food and I opened up
a restaurant in Brooklyn and then the
triangle shifted and then as time went
on cannabis now instead of tech became
at the top point and really I had kind
of gotten out of the tech space but I
stayed in media and food and that really
led to the genesis of Bon Appetit Bon
Appetit connected weed and media and
food
and went full triangle once again and
then that brought me out to California
and Here I am in California and I'm
looking at the industry and somehow I
met these guys here at ease and I was
like oh media food weed while Tech was
my past life you know
man what would happen if I connected the
dots of media food Tech and weed
not just three connections but four yeah
that's when I went from three-point
geometry to 4-point geometry the sacred
geometry what I realized was that
community is the thread that connected
the dots on the Pinsky triangle for all
of us coming out here to California and
immersing myself in this community not
operating from New York from the
sidelines and kind of living in a cave
but being that leo and being fierce on
the top of the mountain and being like
yeah dude right we're in this we're in
this and media were in this in tech
right what I realized was that we've all
got Pinsky triangles man you might not
refer to it as your Pinsky triangle
right but when I take mine and I connect
it to yours and the next person who's
doing this great work in the movement
and this guy who's created this great
company and this guy all these women who
are like pushing this and movement
forward all these amazing people right
when we connect our triangles together
that's when it goes from three-point
geometry to 4-point geometry to sacred
geometry and that's when the triangle
goes fractal okay so this was my
experience I'm sitting here at dinner
October 2017 same conversation and the
person at the table next to me is like
have you ever googled the words triangle
and fractal knew that my last name was
Penske and you googled triangle and
fractal try this at home type it in try
and go fractal what's it called it's
called the sierpinski
triangle dude this is the guy who
created the concept of the triangular
fractal is like my namesake close enough
and then I'm having my moment where I'm
like this is divine this is bigger than
me like that can't be a coincidence
and then I think to myself like you know
this is my moment like in life you know
about finding your purpose sierpinski
right who else is like a sir how about
Sir Alec Guinness obi-wan Kenobi how
about Sir Patrick Stewart jean-luc
Picard like these are my heroes man like
love you Sir Richard Branson but like
you're not obi-wan or Picard did right
and this is when I realized that I was
like maybe like you know looking at
things in this sacred geometry I got out
to California and I started to really
you know kind of totally forgot the
question you asked me by the way well
you should start hitting on it in an in
the lens that I thought was quite
interesting it's that when we are do you
know you illustrate your own Pinsky
triangle and your own way of connecting
really important fields that you're
passionate about community unity to
other peoples again fullest
actualization they've identified they're
most passionate if fields and they've
connected them connecting to yours
connecting to others making that
sierpinski fractal and that speaks to
what the question that I asked because
you've got a really work in
understanding network theory
understanding influence and impact and
finding these nodes that you want to
plug yourself to as you keep climbing up
keep plugging yourself into higher and
higher mentorships and more and more
people from diverse and topology heads
that you can work with and so by doing
that you can advance your
that path that you're paving that road
that you're paving and letting
civilization go down so here's what I
commonly say in terms of the community
man I don't know who I know anymore this
is goes hand-in-hand with saying what
was the question and this is how we met
right having some sort of tech that can
help to lay out this amazing community
not only in cannabis but in terms of the
people that we know right relationships
are at the core trusted relationships
are at the core ok so like this is a
problem that I have had over time 25
years for different careers every single
one of these points has their own really
powerful trusted network of
relationships I don't know who I know
anymore not only that but if I knew who
I knew and algorithms could help me make
proper introductions to accelerate their
roads that they are paving that would be
fantastic so yeah we're working on this
we're working on some stuff in this in
this field this is really important ok
these couple quick simulation questions
on the way out all right what would you
say is a core driving principle of yours
like my core driving principle or like
core value sure well this is the by the
way the triangle is now Reap and renamed
it's called the triangle formerly known
as the Penske triangle this is what
happens in every hero's journey as you
experience the ego death right what I
realized is that a lot of my narrative
and the reason why I bring this up in
relation to your question of core values
is because before the career triangle or
the triangle of trust there was my core
values as I'm sitting recovering 2012
knowing that I was gonna have to make a
shift in my career
thinking it was gonna go in a different
direction after 20-some odd years in
business I asked myself well what has
worked for me and what hasn't what was
important to me if I'm gonna reinvent
myself or move into a different chapter
or evolve into a higher consciousness or
whatever was gonna happen that I didn't
know was gonna happen what did I need to
maintain well passion let's start with
that you better love what you do dude
right for me in 25 years in work I had
peaks and valleys and passion I had
times in my career where I was so
passionate about my work that it didn't
feel like work I had other times in my
career where my life and expenses and
just maintaining might required higher
incomes with less passion could breed an
environment where someone would want to
escape with oxycontin and Warcraft
okay so passion boom and for me it was
the next thing which was what I thought
was like this is when the ego is high I
want to be the CEO I want to be
passionate of what I do and I need to
call the shots
this was the 2013 version of my core
values triangle as that evolved I
realized that maybe it's not that I need
to call the shots because if I want to
be the boss well that limits the
opportunity I have the people I could
work with and so maybe what I need to do
is I need to like make sure if I'm going
to be part of a bigger larger
organization and I'm able to like kind
of beat to my own drum and it was the
rhythm and then that changed to what I
now refer to as inner voice right in
life we have people around us whether
it's our friends spouses parents right
that are trying to impose their voice on
your path
and it takes a lot of self-confidence to
be able to make your inner voice speak
loudest for me in 2013 my inner voice
was telling me dude you're six months
away from turning 40 if you don't lose a
hundred pounds and get a hundred percent
off these pain meds that you've been on
for twelve years you are not gonna make
it two-fifty talk about connecting the
dots of passion in her voice what was
the passion for life bro right I was
like looking for what my next gig was
gonna be and I decided to make my
full-time job me my health that was the
basis of why I was like okay man I've
tried to lose weight as I've started 16
businesses I've tried to get off these
medications as I've tried to be an
entrepreneur and the business needs to
be me and that was only possible because
I had 20 years of foundation and was
able to like not have to be the slave to
going into a job for a paycheck and
crafted a life when I was able to focus
on my food my health and interestingly
enough I'm not gonna let you just leave
this gaming conversation as an escape
thing because the dedication and the
discipline and the motivation and the
enthusiasm that I got from this online
gaming environment and you have facets
of community and you have facets of you
know projecting yourself into as this
other character there are all variants
that have been logged about games
totally but what I did was I gamified my
life I took the concept of leveling up
my character and I said man if I could
level ten toons to max level it's a
progression Raider in World of Warcraft
you can level up in the real world [ __ ]
yeah man I love it
so I gamma fide my weight loss and my
opiate reduction love it literally I
started to set apps on my phone timers
that would time my intake of medication
so I could slowly taper off
I joined Weight Watchers which assign
point values to food and allowed me a
certain value every day and started
logging my intake I used apps from
pharmacies to as pill reminders and you
know I absolutely gamified my experience
of losing weight and tapering off
opiates to level up my life it's so
interesting now as that translates to
cannabis right education is at the core
of changing the hearts and minds of
humanity advancing this movement where's
the incentive I mean in Warcraft the
incentive was not only leveling up your
character and getting legendary weapons
and all this kind of like gear but
really it was it was based in the lore
right they had developed such compelling
IP and characters Tolkien did the same
thing Lord of the Rings yeah Harry
Potter Rowling all of it yeah right so
the depth of the story and the
advancement of the story and not being
able to move through the story unless
you leveled up your character to move
into different zones where you could
further the thing which is your life in
this way you want to get to 50 you want
to be able to continue doing your
creative splash of blood painting this
road and constructing this road this
brings me into the gamification of
cannabis I believe we have an
opportunity to gamified consumption as
cannabis terms into a commodity right
just like media turned into a commodity
and then what did you have you had
Netflix that came in with this
subscription model and all these cable
systems and they
all this content that's by subscription
not not by content music Spotify Apple
music right so I believe that there
needs to be an incentive for consumers
to come to ease or anywhere on a daily
basis and get educated
what's that education incentive it could
be unlocking a new product in the menu
all right what's that and what are you
leveling up I mean like we are lacking
right now in terms of our community
within the cannabis community within the
ecosphere of of ease gaming and gaming
communities have been integral in that
so I see a future where consumers can
come to ease and be given a daily quest
just like in Warcraft and that daily
quest could be like anything from
consume this product which is low-dose
and healthy for you but more importantly
is like sign up a friend to vote go to
this legislative hearing right Pokemon
took the gaming landscape and put it on
the map we're here at Venice man they've
got these scooters birds limes
that's the gamification of
transportation and just like in game you
have a resource again on a ride like
boom so it's the same concept of like
taking the game field and extending that
into into here yeah that's exciting that
these send people on quest to do things
that further increase their awareness
that's interests at how you level up
that's how you level up so this is this
brings us to the collective
consciousness I don't want to take you
off path from your questioning but it's
important that through that process of
living in virtual game environments and
then - and that process of taking the
gaming environment and now taking it
from within the computer and extending
it onto the landscape and fabric of our
reality and then taking also the concept
of fractals and how things are just
repeating versions of themselves and
mate
sure you know how do you connect the
dots well I recently heard about this
concept of our higher selves and how you
know our consciousness right I think of
our consciousness and the expansion of
our consciousness my people in the
beginning of time had basically two
states you had your wake state in your
sleeping state and your consciousness
moved between them and as technology
advanced think of how many different
virtual states right how many suspended
states of consciousness do you have in
every email text message right for me as
a chronic pain patient I was in a waking
dream state opiate state right I believe
that our consciousness moves between all
these different and the question is like
humanity and this is deep dude all right
I want you to know that I'm not attached
to this as what I think is going on I'm
open minded to the possibility that this
might be what's going on hmm
and I've learned to be open-minded to
any and every possibility and detached
from any of them mmm-hmm okay but like
humanity is at the point right now where
we are creating these virtual
environments inside of our computers and
then we are controlling versions of
ourselves our consciousness moves from
our real reality in in game in in
indistinguishable environments yeah yeah
and what's happening is two things are
happening so how is this one not already
an instant distinguishable you know what
the showcase showdown is dude in the
price is right it's what happens at the
end of the price is right you got to go
through all of the prices right before
you get to the showcase showdown boom
please allow me yes you have enough
videotape here I mean like we got plenty
of tape dude you know so
please yes okay but here's my theory on
this if you think about there's always
the big reveal it's at the end dude okay
so here's we talked about this quite a
bit on the show I'm I'm new to 2 to be
always a beginner in life always the
beginner's mind as it is that's right
and anyway so what I believe is
happening in this time in in our evolved
consciousness and our evolution is
humanity at large his technology is
allowing us to create digital versions
of ourselves in games and these massive
multiplayer online they happen to be
controlled playing games whatever you
want to call them but we have ourselves
and then we have our digital selves and
right now we're at the point where it
takes us to control our digital self you
know you're using WASD to move your
character on the keyboard plus your
mouse to move your prescript through
perspective on the camera and you're
moving through this virtual environment
but then what happens like the evolution
is that the character in game becomes
automated it's artificial intelligence
so now instead of you having to like run
to do sixteen different things you could
like automate your character to go do
those things so the character gets
smarter the environment gets more
realistic okay think about the evolution
of that what will happen eventually is
the character will become autonomous and
the environment will be
indistinguishable so now eventually that
character in game could potentially like
have a sense of self right
and then that character would like then
then that would be the only thing
that world that character sense of self
that character sense of self would not
realize necessarily that it was being
controlled mostly automated but still
some higher consciousness that has some
sort of influence so now take the
fractal theory and fractal it forward
like this is our thing and this is
what's happening in game pull it back
right if we all started from this
oneness if the Big Bang thing right if
we all started from this thing and we're
all expanding out right but we're all
connected right then maybe your
consciousness is just moving into
multiple inner fractal iterations and we
and in our humanity and what allows us
to have this expanded consciousness is
the realization that holy [ __ ] man maybe
like we're not fully in control I mean
we are but our Koch if our consciousness
is moving you know through different
dimensions I look at reality in a like I
I have a theory and not attached like
we're like these vibrating things us
were collections of organized vibrating
things right and we're like antennas and
receivers we receive vibration we send
vibration right the electrical alignment
of the energy and our configuration the
golden ratio right it it means that we
as an antenna are like we're watching
we're all tuned in to reality because
the vibration of everything around us in
terms in conjunction with the way we
receive it imagine like humanity is
tuned in to Channel seven that's what
we're all watching that's what this is
channel 7 now back in the beginning of
time right and I'm not a yogi and I'm
not a you know among
right but I from what I think I
understand humanity and has been
changing our vibrational frequency
through things like breathing meditation
what I refer to as primitive ways of
changing your the way you receive react
perceive reality now technology is
allowing for us to you know do that in
different ways not necessarily through
breathing although they do have float
things and vibrational tables and light
things that like you know can all this
different stuff which is super cool but
then you have the plant mm-hmm and then
you have these anthea genic plants that
can also change our frequency right I
think of the next collective movement
right cannabis movement led to the
cannabis industry which leads to the
psychedelics movement which leads to the
psychedelics industry right but at the
same time what's happening is like weed
is like making it so that our vessel is
so that our body is balanced right
dimethyltryptamine right and I don't
refer to it as ayahuasca because
ayahuasca is a primitive you know I've
never done ayahuasca but I've hid the
DMT a lot right ayahuasca I refer to or
think of it like an edible like you're
ingesting it it's like this long journey
even psychedelics like LSD mushrooms
right all of these compounds that give
you an extended psychedelic journey it's
very different than punching and
piercing the veil of reality in ten
minutes
and then returning back and having an
opportunity reflect same technology
that's being used right now to extract
THC from cannabis is being used to
extract DMT from a mosa bark and from
vacation
tree right by the way which like grows
wild and natively and like you know
Israel and like in these parts of the
earth where like you know all the old
biblical stuff started to happen so I've
never really been a student of religion
I'm come from a science background what
starts to happen is I get out to
California and I start to really connect
the dots between a lot of this mystical
stuff and a lot of this science stuff
totally and this is really what I think
is the most interesting thing to me
right now
is how is it that all this [ __ ] that was
written down back in the day all this
sacred geometry especially is all so
also the same geometric shapes that
we're seeing in science all over the
place you know so you talked about like
the correlation between between you know
science and mysticism and spirituality
and the the simulation I love that this
is the simulation man I'm totally
open-minded to the concept of of us
already being in it you know you've
heard a lot of provocative thought
leaders also speaking to that absolutely
I think that's really the advantage of
my journey with with DMT and it doesn't
matter we hear a lot from people on the
show that it doesn't matter no actually
it doesn't matter it's a very
interesting thought experiment to
calculate and open one's awareness to
understanding simulation theory
understanding how you've indicated
throughout the conversation the the
indistinguishable realities so as we
play in indistinguishable realities with
our characters and automate processes
and you can when you can hit a vape pen
and hold your breath three huge hits
hold your breath each time as long
you can and all of a sudden you like pop
the fabric of reality the veil you
pierce the veil of reality right and
what happens is for that short period of
time you see things in a different
physics change the way things sound the
configuration of atoms all this stuff is
now you're looking at the fabric of
reality looking through the fabric of
reality right and seeing perception and
seeing things through a different lens
this is gonna get really good when we
are able to completely map neural
signatures during subjective mystical
experiences and then replay them for
other people it's short acting short
acting transformative psychedelic
experiences allow us to have that
journey to stepped into that parallel
perspective and then we're back and that
we could reflect totally no disrespect
to LSD man but it is like really
confusing sometimes okay you know what I
mean when you're like you know to put
all these pieces together while you're
like having this extended journey
piercing the veil with a DMT quickly and
they're coming back and I do like this
serious importance with science with
with running with scientific method with
running hypotheses and then like I said
being able to display one subjective
experience to other people afterward and
then do that at mass scales and then say
okay we are actually piercing a veil of
reality look at what we're understanding
now now we're really levelling up as a
civilization it's exciting stuff and I
like how you talked about your some of
your core values being about that
passion that that straight-up you love
what you do so much doesn't feel like
work that's a tremendously important
things to pass on to children if you
could rebuild civilization from scratch
how would you design it
I would design it in a way that had a I
would design a universal translator at
the core I think that the ability for us
civilization to be able to communicate
the Arabic language is a and the lack of
one group being able to even understand
so through communication I would have
some sort of universal communication
from the start yeah that's a really good
that's a really good one communication
has been something you've been referring
to several times and it's well not just
community but communication like you
know communication itself yeah the way
that human animals communicate is a
direct representation of the society
that they build so the better we
communicate the better society we build
we talked a lot about this already what
exists pass our 3d reality but let's
let's see what else do you have to add
to the existing reality I think that
passed the 3d reality I think what we
don't see is we don't see like we're
communicating right now through
structured vibrations through our voice
have you seen doing the movi doing maybe
okay
go check out June yeah I know I'm no
scientist and then dope cannabinoid
scientists I got it
dune actually they used their voice as a
weapon they would like they would go
blah and like that and it would like
like it would like whoa
so like this is the deal dude
we are like this Callie like I've heard
about Callie vibes man my whole life I
didn't realize that like it wasn't just
Callie vibes it's like now the cannabis
industry got me into vibrations of light
music got me into vibrations of sound
California
specifically like this dude on the beach
the sacred geometry guy right this is
like the vibration of us so what I think
is beyond our 3-dimensional perception
is like the energy field that surrounds
us you ever notice how when you hug
somebody
some people like it's just flesh and
then other people like it's like yeah
right so I'm starting to really tap more
into us as as antennas receivers and
transmitters yeah and and really
starting to like be able to like do you
know my energy field extends like 50
feet man almost in every direction and I
can't see it but I see that that is an
example of something that's outside of
the perception of our regular
three-dimensional environment is like
the energy that we as people or has
living or even right all of it and then
what about the non-linearity of time
well if in fact our consciousness is
moving between different dimensions of
time and space you know like this
23andme came back and I'm this
ninety-eight ninety-nine point eight
percent Ashkenazi Jew and who what what
is ninety-nine point eight percent of
anything right I think of like you know
this sierpinski character I think of
like you know these like ancient you
know what if I'm an ancient being and a
future being and a present being all at
the same time you know I I recently had
an OP
Trinity to to sit with someone who I
believe has the ability to have higher
consciousness speak through them and man
things have been happening I think it's
called synchronicities how is it that
all these things keep happening to me
faster and faster and faster people come
into their lives people come into my
life
and they are bearing the mark of the
sacred geometry one person it's a pair
of earrings a triangular and structure
for me man
the things cuz you're paving the road
well I thought that that was the
question I'm like what's happening and
people coming into my life bearing the
mark and then all of a sudden like you
know like the chaos aligns and it's
because of some energy that comes in
that is like we're bearing the mark of
the triangle and I'm like what is it i
sat with someone who is like I'm like is
it like are they bread crumbs are they
are they signal like are people coming
like what's happening what is happening
and one perspective was it's not people
that are coming into your life I think
the exact quote was it's you dude it's
you and you ever come up from underwater
where you're like underwater and then
all of a sudden you like you're you're
suffocating right or even you're
underwater and you're holding your
breath but when you come above water in
you're like oh and I had that moment man
as soon as it was like it's you and I
realized wow dude that's when I really
thought about time being nonlinear what
if past-president future were happening
all right now and what if it was
actually my Higher Self like I am a
artificially intelligent fully automated
in-game character that is being
influenced by my higher consciousness
Wow
it's a good summary of our last little
bit of convo yeah you know this is an
important thought experiment to actually
embody and really subjectively aim to
understand better as individuals and
then talk to others about it's a very
interesting one ok the last couple
questions we talked about this briefly
but do you think this is a simulation
I'm open-minded to the possibility that
it very well may be I'm not attached to
that reality but I'd say that I would be
accepting of that reality given my life
experience in gaming as that translates
to future generations I think that the
kids coming up these days have a
completely leg up advantage by living in
these virtual worlds from childhood as
it relates to being open minded for that
and as time moves forward and as
technology advances and as we create
virtual environments that become
realistic and we separate the need for
having there to be a screen have you
seen the new Star Trek discovery do you
know that the ship is powered by
psychedelic mushrooms and warp drive is
now quantum drive and they jump between
parallel universes
remember Star Trek had the first
interracial kiss back in the 60s right
this is a perfect example of media kind
of setting the stage for future
generations and the possibilities of
what might actually be and hopefully
we're doing that with the show yeah dude
this is this is the deal dude the
simulation series hopefully nice last
question please what do you think's the
most beautiful thing in the world
[Music]
us I think the most beautiful thing in
the world is us not you not me but like
collectively man I think it's beautiful
as we harmonize in our vibrational
frequency I think it's beautiful as we
harmonize in our purpose
I think harmony is beautiful
earth is beautiful and earth becoming a
pinnacle the pinnacle of what it can be
in its fullest prosperity is gorgeous
full harmony mr. Pinsky what a pleasure
this has been amazing thank you so much
for the opportunity this has been super
fun love it love it yeah super
wide-ranging conversation - you had some
really powerful wisdoms in this show we
really appreciate learning more about
all things related to cannabis as a
nutrient for civilization this has been
really enlightening everyone I thank you
so much we thank you so much for tuning
and greatly greatly appreciate it we'd
love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below let us know join the
community and the conversations chat
about it let's spread these messages and
get talking to other people about it
check out Jason's links below to his
work to ease and Bon Appetit and more
check that all out in the links below
and continue supporting us below as well
we need to do cool things like continue
coming on site to great places like Los
Angeles and talking to epic leaders like
mr. Pinsky and go and build the future
everyone go and manifest your destiny
into the world we love you so much
thanks for tuning in peace peace I love
it come here
tell me yeah good stuff that was all
that was everything was good [ __ ] man
thank you
okay so it's Pinsky in the brain we're
here today with Alan take over it's
wrong with Penske we're here with Alan
and we are in the simulation series here
to discuss all things considered Alan
please Helen please tell us have a
please tell us all right all right so me
me me me me 20 dwarves 20 dwarves 20
dwarves can you do it with me 20 door
door - I'm on it - wharves ok as you are
now you may start please oh all right
mmm